[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'autre tient politique
avec lionel vast le maire d'andrésy
bonjour monsieur le maire garde alors
andrésy c'est une ville qui dans le
nord-est des ivy d'à peu près une
dizaine kilomètres de saint germain en
laye une vingtaine de kilomètres de
paris sur la rive droite de la seine
c'est une ville qui a dû non pas être
une cité batelière qui comporte
aujourd'hui à peu près 14 mille
habitants est plutôt de populations
jeunes puisque il ya la propension plus
de 60 ans est un peu moindre que dans le
reste du département
alors vous avez été élu maire d'andrésy
aux dernières municipales au deuxième
tour vous êtes donc un nouveau maire
comment comment se passent vos premiers
mois de mandat
ça se passe très bien d'une part la
passation de pouvoir s'est très très
bien fait avec l'ancienne majorité qui
était pourtant pas de mon camp mais ils
ont vraiment très bien joué le jeu on
est arrivé avec une certaine euphorie
pour enfin mettre en oeuvre notre
programme
et puis et en même temps à côté de cette
euphorie on avait une grosse
responsabilité parce que voilà du jour
au lendemain se retrouve à la tête d'une
ville est effectivement de ne plus de 13
mille habitants une collectivité de plus
de 200 agents le tout dans un contexte
financier contraint avec cette crise
sanitaire
mais effectivement ses premiers pas se
déroule vraiment très bien vous étiez
préparé à cette fonction ou est ce qu'il
ya des choses qui nous ont surprises
peut-être alors on était quand même bien
préparés à cette fonction j'ai été
conseiller municipal raid opposition
pendant six années ainsi qu'une partie
de mon équipe donc on connaissait quand
même beaucoup des services on
connaissait beaucoup de dossiers mais
effectivement on a quand même des
surprises on découvre ou des dossiers
qui sont avancés qui était un peu top
secret et puis on découvre comme vous
dédie la gestion d'une ville depuis 200
agents ça par contre ça ça prend petit à
petit sur le bas alors vous êtes
enseignant dans la vie vous continuez
d'ailleurs votre maîtrise by métier
d'enseignant on peut concilier
facilement les deux vous alors vous avez
vous travaillé je ne sais pas quarante
huit heures par jour
non j'ai dû faire quand même quelques
chaudes et des choix je suis enseignant
en sciences économiques et sociales au
lycée j'ai réduit de 30% maison de cours
au lycée
par contre j'ai arrêté les cours en
classe préparatoire
parce que là je ne pouvais pas suivre et
j'arrive effectivement à manier les deux
et je suis même très content d'avoir un
pied en mairie et un autre pied dans la
vie professionnelle
parce que ça permet vraiment de rester
connecté à la vie réelle
ça me permet par ailleurs de me
déconnecter de temps en temps du poids
des lourdeurs administratives même de du
poids des responsabilités que je peux
avoir en tant que maire alors vous êtes
membre d'europe écologie les verts vous
êtes donc à merveille vous êtes le seul
d'ailleurs mr merde et des yvelines
alors qu'ils aient eu un gros succès de
votre parti on pense à lyon pense à
bordeaux
d'autres villes encore qu'est ce que
c'est un maire écolo aujourd'hui alors
effectivement je suis le seul maire de
daisy vide en tout cas pour les villes
de plus de 10 mille habitants on
m'appelle déjà d'ailleurs le ver
solitaire jeudi fermée refaire ça c'est
une bonne question
alors c'est un maire qui d'une part
essaye de construire des projets avec
toujours une vision de long terme
l'objectif c'est de ne pas sacrifier la
vie de nos enfants et de nos
petits-enfants
un maire écologiste c'est un maire qui
essaye de monter des projets en tenant
compte de quatre dimensions une
dimension économique assez traditionnel
l'objectif bien évidemment c'est que
c'est de ne pas laisser un endettement à
nous à nos enfants
et puis cette dimension économique doit
prendre en compte aussi l'importance du
tissu économique local deuxième
dimension à prendre en compte une
dimension sociale on essaye de monter
des projets qui garantissent l'équité
l'égalité sociale entre les catégories
sociales mais surtout l'équité entre les
quartiers
très souvent les mères ont tendance à
priori
et le centre ville où les quartiers très
dynamique en oubliant des quartiers
déshérités une dimension
environnementale
tous les projets doivent se construire
en respectant notre environnement notre
biodiversité
voilà on développe des actions autour la
gestion écologique des espaces verts on
a un projet de ferme municipal on
développe des actions durables au niveau
de l'alimentation bio des économies
d'énergie
on développe des actions en faveur du
tri de réduction des déchets on essaie
de développer le covoiturage les
mobilités douces et l'écho urbanisme
dans tous les futurs projets immobiliers
et la quatrième dimension
cette dimension participative ils font
construire les grands projets avec les
habitants parce que finalement au niveau
d'une ville c'est relativement facile
d'être connecté aux habitants et surtout
ce sont nos meilleurs experts pour
connaître les problématiques de la rue
ou du quartier voilà ce que c'est qu'un
les conseils municipaux étaient en
visioconférence si je peux dire on peut
on peur on peut les regarder en direct
abbas et en toute transparence voilà
c'est on essaye de développer cette
cette transparence
on essaye aussi de laisser beaucoup de
place aux élus de l'opposition je donne
un simple exemple j'ai stoppé la tribune
de la majorité des élus de la ville dans
journal municipal
j'ai laissé une page entière à
l'opposition un meilleur confort unique
quoi est ce que il ya eu le tour de
france est passé dans les yvelines
d'autres jouent à ce que comme votre
collègue de lyon vous avez vous tous
vous trouvez que c'est un un sport un
peu machiste et et non non non
franchement alors hgd peur les petites
phrases de mes camarades écologistes qui
finalement sont des petites phrases
impopulaire et qui sont totalement
stérile le tour de france
moi j'aime bien et je respecte toutes
celles et ceux qui le pratiquent août
ils l'adorent
le machisme ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on a on m'avait déjà dit et une tour
de france a fait des efforts donc
effectivement moi je ne fais pas partie
de ces écologistes qui a
voilà qui lance des petites phrases
polémiques alors pour conclure je vais
vous citer quatre personnalités qui sont
originaires de brézillet le peintre
alfred sisley ya le chanteur mouloudji
marcel mouloudji
il ya le célèbre commissaire broussard
et puis ils sont tous natifs de nazis et
scana dont vous sentez le plus proche de
vous hanter plutôt éloigné pas écouté je
suis un peu embêté parce que parmi ces
trois personnes étaient encore vivants
c'est le commissaire broussard messages
osés mais il était conseiller municipal
à l'époque avait dans la majorité ou
foyer beau mais au delà du commissaire
broussard qui était un homme très
sympathique avec beaucoup de compétence
j'avoue que j'ai un petit un petit un
petit penchant pour moi outil parce que
moi même je suis musicien et parce que
ça a été un chanteur très engagé et
j'apprécie c'est ces artistes qui sont
capables de s'engager politiquement
lorsqu'ils ont des valeurs à défendre et
même si les coquelicots sont rouges
ils sont censés des verts y sont
sensibles exactement
merci infiniment lionel vast et puis on
aura l'occasion sans doute de reparler
plus profondément d'écologie parce que
ces autos fausses qui vous tient à coeur
et c'est important de savoir ce que
c'est voilà maire écologiste dans une
ville comme en vrai dit merci infiniment
avec grand plaisir embarqué cieux
[Musique]